Hey everyone.
So we're continuing with the business
and your election series
and today I'm highlighting the d.
A. Manifesto, the d.
S. Rescue Plan for South Africa.
This manifesto was launched,
released over the weekend
and I have been waiting
to get my hands on this manifesto.
It was 56 pages long with seven key rescue missions,
rescue plans of the d.
A. Highlights um
in terms of what their plan is
should they win on the coming elections.
So the dear has finally released the manifesto
and I'm excited to go through it
just to highlight a few
things that have stood out for me
as it pertains to the economy,
businesses and entrepreneurship
and their plans for the future.
I mean um, we are at a critical time now in South Africa.
We need to be either re electing the a N
C or um seeing a new political party come into power.
So let's just get right into it.
So in the foreword that was drafted by Johnston Hasan,
um, the d. A. Says that for the first time in 30 years
South Africa has a realistic chance of electing a new
government this year.
And for the first time in 30 years the d. A.
Has a credible path into national government
if enough of their voters turn out on election day.
So he announced the creation of the multi party
charter for South Africa as an initiative.
Um, this was first announced last year
at the Federal Congress.
Um, in April 2023.
So he is foraging a common vision amongst opposition
parties to work together
to unseat the current governing party
and the charter provides a clear path
to power for alternative government.
So he highlights the change as possible
because already the N C
fell below 50% in the previous selection.
So he is emphasizing the fact that there is possibility
for the N C
to lose power.
And this is all just put together in his forward, um,
leading into the plan for South Africa and the rescue.
Um, items that um,
the d a is ready to take on.
So in addition to that,
voters do not put the multi party
charter in a position to succeed their other parties
such as the E, F,
F waiting in the wings to form a coalition
of corruption with the a, N, C.
So the best way to prevent a coalition between the a, N,
C and the E, F,
F from finally
destroying South Africa is by voting for a strong d a.
In this election.
Voting for the d
a is a win win proposition.
A vote for the d
a is a vote to help the multi charter,
the multi party charter to win.
Um, a vote for the d
a is a vote to prevent an a and C, E,
F, F coalition.
So here are the seven APEX priorities.
Um, by the d. A.
No. 1, create 2 million new jobs.
2. End load shedding
and Water shedding. 3,
half the rate of violent crimes
including murder,
attempted murder
and gender based violence.
4. Abolish cater
deployment in favour of married based appointment
and a capable state that delivers for all.
No. 5, lift six million people out of poverty.
Number six, triple the number of Grade 4 learners
who can read for meaning. And No. 7,
ensure quality health care for all
irrespective of economic status.
So these are the key seven,
top seven, um,
priorities for d
a coming into the 2024 elections.
So the d s says
as a result of cater deployment,
corruption and criminality,
we no longer have a reliable power supply.
Crime is out of control.
Too many children cannot read and
write at the required level.
Their water shortages all over the country.
Our ports are failing
and towns and cities are in decay.
Problems have killed
South Africa's
economic growth prospects
and the ability to create jobs. So the d
a has a plan to rescue South Africa from state collapse.
And it will start by fixing
what is broken in government
by abolishing cater deployment,
firing corrupt officials
and appointing competent
people with the skills to deliver services.
They will build a capable
stage to partner with a private sector and civil
society to rescue
South Africa.
So this whole of society
approach has worked
even in every place that they govern
and they plan to replicate it across the country
to get South Africa moving in the right direction.
So The d. A. Says that the national
government's inability to generate meaningful
employment for millions
of people stems from the a
N C's misguided
belief that the state must exercise
control over the economy.
And this approach
has only resulted in greater
dependency on a failing state,
the threatening of investment
and economic
misery for millions of South Africans.
So the N C's perception
of the private
sector as an enemy has be,
has dissentifies
enterprises
innovations
and therefore
it has also, um,
affected job
creation. So the d. A.
Believes in building a capable state
which recognizes that its role is to create
the conditions
for private
enterprises to flourish.
So they've also noted
how the government's failure
affects us as, um,
the general public.
Um, that it deepened
the unemployment crisis
where the youth were hit the,
the hardest
with over 70% of young people aged
between 15 and 24 years
aren't able to get proper jobs.
Um, they illustrated that
the failure of the government to create
the conditions
for businesses to grow,
our unemployment
rate has increased
and the employment rate
continues to rise
when you include
discouraged
work seekers.
So the d. A. Plans to create
more jobs for our youth by
introducing
a Youth Employment
Opportunity
Certificate.
This certificate
will empower
young people
to break free from the constraints of the minimum wage,
giving them better chances of finding jobs.
The goal is
to make it easier for young people
aged between 18 and 34
to move from not having a job
to having um
won by offering
flexible employment terms.
So this certificate
will be valid
for two years
and will be implemented to give
unemployed people
who have not
been employed forever
for over 12 months or more
the right to exempt
themselves from sectorial
wage agreements.
And the policy
will make it easier for employers
to hire those
who have been out of work
for long periods of time.
So the d. A. Says that it will get our public finances
under control
by stabilizing
public debt
by encouraging
responsible
fiscal spending,
improving state owned enterprises
and developing
a saving culture.
And they also want to slash the red tape that holds
back small businesses
through accelerating
the introduction of one stop shops,
making it easier for informal
traders to sell
their goods
or services.
In addition to that, the d.
A. Will develop a competitive
export oriented economy
by making infrastructure development a top priority
by implementing industrial and competition policy
that supports all sectors equally
and by strengthening trade and internationalism.
In terms of ending water and load shedding,
um, they've highlighted that load shedding is a most
significant threat to South Africa's social and
economic stability.
And that the national government
has failed to ensure a reliable power supply due to,
to its insistence of utilizing
an outdated model of state lead power generation.
So the focus of the state
control has resulted in many missed opportunities,
weak policy
And unreliable energy supply due to resource capacity
and administration constraints of the state.
So the dear government
will move away from the reliance on Eskim
and increase the usage of renewable energy sources
by building local manufacturing capacity
for renewable energy technologies
by reducing
high tariffs on imports of renewable energy technology
such as P V panels and other goods
and committing to achieving a net zero carbon emissions.
That's it for the d.
A manifesto review.
Let me know in the comments.
Let's discuss.
Will the d. A.
Be getting your vote based on this manifesto?
What are your thoughts surrounding their ability to um,
run the country and turn things around?
And also they are drive to have a multi party charter.
What are your thoughts about that?
Let's keep the conversation going.